let's get into it on your anvils you
guys have a cloth go ahead and remove
that for me what you guys have in front
of you are bars of 1095 and 15 N20 steel
which we want you to use to make
Damascus billets and Forge them into
blades
but today we don't want you to build
signature blades in your signature Style
no gentlemen we got something much more
complex much more intricate a blade that
was designed specifically for this
competition by Dave Baker himself
today I want you to build this
gentlemen this is no mistake
the blade you guys are going to be
building is laying behind this display
today's competition we're gonna be
testing your visualization skills in a
competition we're calling the memory
game
guys I'm gonna call you up one at a time
and you're each gonna have 20 seconds
and only 20 seconds to check out the
blade behind this display and commit it
to memory because after that 20 seconds
is completed you will not get to look at
the blade again you guys ready
Jade you're up first
come on up bud
yeah
yeah Matt you're up come on
it has a trailing tip on it with a
serrated back
it's going to be a lot to remember
Connor your turn bud
generally I think my memory is pretty
good but uh 20 seconds is not a lot of
time okay
it's a huge B unnecessarily complicated
three two one time's up
and C that's pretty cool all right I'll
give you that one it's a pretty cool
knife gentlemen you guys have three
hours on the clock good luck your time
starts now cool comment collected we
have to do multi-layer Damascus never
done that before so I can't make any
mistakes
I try and get all my loose pieces
together and even on all sides and I
toss it in the Forge so far so good I
don't hear any dead space so I'm feeling
very confident that my Forge welding was
a success and now it's time to start
drawing it out and shaping the blade
my belt's finally up to heat I'm ready
to go
the bill is no good
if you don't get a good Damascus weld
you don't have a good Billet you got
nothing to turn in
gonna give me one of these it looks like
it's welding pretty well
and back in the fire with you
at this point my welds are set my bill
is starting to dry out and I'm cruising
man
it'd be good to set myself apart from
the competition so I'm going to put in a
ladder pattern oh yeah you put a ladder
pattern in that's awesome my billet's
looking great and out of the corner of
my eye I see other Smith setting up to
do some Damascus pattern so I'm thinking
I need to do the same
now we've got two
next part of making this blade
I spent a lot of time drawing fill it
out so much metal and it's still too
thick so I'm just gonna ditch some of
this
I'm grinding on it I'm trying to get
that stupid thing to come off
it's gonna be fun finally it pops free
so I got to get it in Forge as soon as I
can
that's ugly
nice I've got the Billet prepped I'm
gonna Forge my entire profile and then
I'm gonna clean it up on the grinder
good I'm happy with the rough shape that
I have I'm ready to move over to the
grinder
I'm on the grinder I noticed that
there's a d-lam on the side of the blade
oh no if I don't get that out of there
that's going to be a place for a crack
the only way to fix it is to weld it up
that well doesn't solve that problem
that could snap the blade oh yeah welded
it up and it's good to go
time is of the essence right now I can
feel the adrenaline pumping through my
veins and I'm like we're going to get
this done
that'll do I feel good about the profile
I'm ready to quench
Caden went into the oil but he was
pretty hot yeah
get a quick Glimpse at the blade and
it's dead straight I am stoked perfect
Connor's still got a bit of a drop point
it doesn't really have a curvature to
the spine it's more like a peak
I heat it up to quench temp when I throw
it in
all right Connor's quenched that's nice
seems pretty straight I'm good to go
and then I realized oh man it's got
these weird scallopy serrations I gotta
put those in
eight serrations on the back of a blade
why'd you put them on here
this is your evil
that's ugly if I forget any of
these features and the guys around me
remember it that's a plane ticket home
generally I think my memory is pretty
good but I'm just gonna have to roll
with it
there we go it's awesome
Maps quenched
it's looking straight I'm starting to
get happier now and that's when I
realized I forgot the serration oh I
don't want to get sent home over not
having the feature in the knife so now
we're in Mad Dash mode I'm putting these
iterations in the best I can
five four three two one gentlemen turn
off your machines put down your tools
this round is over
right blade Smiths welcome to the
strength test copper pipe chop
looks simple but this copper pipe loves
tearing up edges so I'm gonna give them
a few whacks and test the edges overall
construction of your knives you know
what they do to the pipes it's cool to
see but the big thing is what the pipes
do to your blades Jayden here first you
ready to go take it easy but take it
okay
copper is really soft and kind of likes
to stick on the steel it could really
easily roll it or do all sorts of things
to it my heart is racing at this point
because I don't know what's going to
happen
that was gnarly
all right Jim you got all we asked for
so your memory must be pretty good
a couple little chips and rolls
but otherwise handle's comfortable great
job thank you I'm glad I went first that
was horrifying back you ready for this
I'm terrified that's all right we'll do
it anyway
I've seen past competitions where the
copper pipe shop does a lot of damage to
blades and I'm worried that my blade
might be next I can't count how fast my
heart's beating
all right Matt you survived good job
Blade's still straight you still have an
edge there but uh what happened in those
egg pins there they're not there it's
one of the things we asked for the
Mosaic pin that I made made it too short
I had to abandon it to make a functional
weapon okay it's not a parameter failure
but that's a bit of an issue
the handle is fine it's actually
comfortable back here up here it's a bit
on thick side
but your Blade's still straight still
sharp hand is still on good job thank
you
Connor how you feeling less good than I
was before I saw you wailing away but
it's all right okay
going into testing my biggest concern is
that it's gonna tear his hand up because
it's not a finished handle so I'm a
little nervous about him swinging that
at the copper pipe
let me talk to these guys for a second
feel it right there you got a little
right there
[Music]
Connor I got a big issue with this
I know you're rushed at the end but this
handle is extremely sharp right where my
finger is and then the end of the blade
right here is almost like a little shiv
digging into my finger
leather tougher than my skin
the marks is digging into the leather
I would not feel comfortable unless I
was a random love swinging this and
that's totally unfair to your
competitors I understand completely what
kind of man we hate to see somebody go
this way Jay unfortunately can't fairly
test your weapon I'm gonna say thanks
for coming out you fought really hard
you did great in round one but
unfortunately your time here in the
forges ended
I understand thank you
damn good fight man in a way I'm
relieved that they gave it a vote enough
confidence I do not want Jay to swing
that hurt himself I wouldn't put it in
my hands and my hands are pretty
calloused so it's unfair for me to
expect anybody else to do that
all in all it's not too bad I
accomplished my two goals don't get out
on round one don't let my face on fire
check and check I feel pretty good about
it